Given A Nightmare on Elm Street's immense
popularity and its status in the modern horror
film canon, you would think there would be
very few facts or secrets about the 1984 horror
classic left to discover.
But thanks to an obscure deleted scene, you
would be oh-so wrong.
A scrapped scene from the film has recently
resurfaced online, and it completely changes
everything we thought we knew about the burnt-up
serial killer Freddy Krueger and his most
well-known would-be victim, 15-year-old Nancy
Thompson.
The sequence, first included in the 1996 Laserdisc
release of A Nightmare on Elm Street and only
included sporadically in later home video
releases, is an extended version of the conversation
Nancy and her mother Marge have in the original
cut of the film.
Marge takes Nancy down to their basement and
explains to her that Krueger was "a filthy
child murderer" who was freed on a legal technicality.
Marge says that she and the other parents
of Springwood, Ohio tracked Krueger down and
discovered him hiding in a boiler room where
he used to take his young victims.
The parents then doused the place in gasoline
and lit it up in an attempt to get rid of
Krueger for good, a strategy echoed by Nancy
at the end of the film..
In the theatrical version of A Nightmare on
Elm Street, Nancy's mother assures her that
Krueger can't get to her, and that he's dead
because she's killed him.
Marge then pulls out one of Krueger's razor
gloves to prove that he's gone and that Nancy
can rest easy.
But in this alternate scene, there's additional
exposition between the moment Marge admits
to burning Krueger alive and when she unwraps
the killer's famous weapon.
Nancy's mother discloses the real motivation
behind murdering Krueger: she and her fellow
neighborhood parents wanted revenge after
Krueger had already killed some of their own
children.
That's right: Nancy and her friends all had
siblings Krueger had already murdered.
"You too Nancy.
You weren't always an only child"
With those few sentences from her mom, Nancy
realizes that Krueger isn't just some random,
deranged man with supernatural abilities and
a desire to kill children and teenagers.
He isn't even just a killer who seeks vengeance
after getting burned alive all those years
ago.
No, he's a murderer who took away a piece
of Nancy's family, who left her parents bereft
and her without a sibling and who also did
the same to her closest friends and their
families.
"They all had a brother or sister once."
As such, this reveal seems to alter the entire
dynamic between Nancy and Krueger and instills
in the teen a new reason to go after the monster.
Though the deleted sequence has been readily
available to watch online for years now, there's
a chance plenty A Nightmare on Elm Street
fans haven't yet seen it which is kind of
huge considering how drastically it could
change their thinking of both the original
1984 film and the film series as a whole.
If Craven had kept this version of the storytelling
session in the theatrical version of A Nightmare
on Elm Street, it potentially could have had
a domino effect on the events of every franchise
installment thereafter.
Each new series entry picks up and expands
on what came before it.
So if the official Nightmare lore included
the fact that Nancy had a sibling who was
killed, that could have been used to explain
her reemergence in 1987's A Nightmare on Elm
Street 3: Dream Warriors.
It definitely would have provided her with
even more motivation to put Krueger down in
the classic original Nightmare, as if slipping
her supernatural phone tongue wasn't enough.
"So it's okay now.
You can sleep."